Disney movies have more than their fair
share of cool hidden Easter eggs they
also happen to have lots of weird
controversial and just plain creepy
secrets in moments that only someone
who's truly obsessed would bother
compiling into the single list so here
we go number one the lion Kings sex test
remember watching 1994 is the Lion King
as a kid being enthralled by Simba
struggle to face his fears and confront
his villainous uncle and being totally
distracted by the sudden unmistakable
appearance of sex now well tell that to
the American Life League the
conservative group that in 1995 claimed
the word sex is spelled out in a dust
cloud in the sky after Simba flops down
onto the ledge but Tom Sita one of the
movies animators has since explained
that the dust cloud actually spells out
SFX
or special effects a kind of signature
inserted into one frame of animation by
Disney effects team and you know that's
probably true because slipping a word as
tame as sex into a single frame of an
animated movie is unbelievably tame if
an animator really wanted to mess with
people's heads you put in something way
more risque like butt or Winky or
something like that or maybe he just
thrown a picture of a topless woman
speaking of which number two the
rescuers topless woman picture in 1999
Disney made a surprising announcement
saying that it was going to recall 3.4
million copies of its 1977 animated film
the rescuers just three days after the
movie's second release on home video a
reason that was even more shocking
hidden within two frames of the movie
was an inexplicable photo of a naked
lady apparently sometime between the
film's completion and its debut in
theaters someone in the distribution
chain slipped the image in unbeknownst
to Disney or really anyone the image
probably would never have been
discovered at all if it weren't for
improvements in video technology that
allowed people to freeze the movie and
find its secret shame
nearly three months later the rescuers
was released once again this time
without the nudie pics meanwhile copies
of the movie that escaped the recall are
fetching big bucks on eBay demanding
whopping prices between 4 and 11 old
dollars never mind anyway this isn't
really that bad that's not like one of
the animators drew a woman not wearing
any under
also speaking of which number three
Jessica Rabbit isn't wearing underpants
in 1988 spoo Framed Roger Rabbit femme
fatale Jessica Rabbit has an infamous
line I'm not bad I'm just drawn that way
as it turns out that was a little truer
than anyone could have guessed just as
the video release of the rescuers
revealed a hidden controversy so too did
the laserdisc release of Roger Rabbit
when Jessica and Eddie valiant get into
a car crash
they're both thrown from their cab the
briefest moments only about a frame or
two viewers can see that the animators
declined to draw any definitive
underwear between Jessica's legs so is a
missing line of paint enough to cause a
panic is it creepy that Mickey owns a
dog and his friends with goofy who is
also a dog have the answer to both
questions is yes reports from the time
said that the retailer sold out of the
laserdisc for the movie one day after
initial news of the missing undies hit
the media back in 1994
fortunately for fans of decency
everywhere the missing underthings were
inserted into the movies DVD release but
come on this was clearly much ado about
nothing nobody could actually see any
genitals or anything I'm pretty sure and
on that note number for all the genitals
and the Little Mermaid a little mermaid
from 1989 doesn't seem like it have much
room for any naughty bits especially
since all the movies under siege
innocents have well people parts on the
top and fish parts on the bottom but
when the evil Ursula tries to trick Erik
into marrying her the Minister
officiating the wedding seems to be
excited by the impending nuptials
Disney's tom sito said that what looks
like the guy's little Minister is
actually just his knee but then on the
cover art of the original Home Video
released for The Little Mermaid
many people have found what sure does
look like an important part of the male
anatomy hidden in a spire on an
underwater castle one report claims that
the artist who is a freelance
illustrator working on the cover and not
a Disney employee was simply in a rush
to finish the cover art and stayed up
late that night before the deadline to
finish the job in the end the minister
seems to have survived various video
releases untouched while the cover image
heads conspicuous by her cut
seriously though people are making
mountains out of molehills here it makes
sense to get upset only if there was
something truly objectionable in these
Disney movies there's something like a
never-ending parade of stereotypes and
blatant racism
number five the parade of stereotypes
and blatant racism in Disney movies in
general okay so a whole lot of Disney
movies were made and released during a
time in America we're concepts like oh I
don't know ethnic and racial sensitivity
or political correctness weren't really
like things as a result some of these
flicks have aged pretty horribly due to
the inclusion of characters that are
unavoidably offensive by today's
standards in fact one Disney movie is so
entirely racist that it will simply
never be released on video ever where to
start in DUMBO from 1941 the baby
elephant encounters a group of crows who
have since been identified as racist
caricatures of African Americans case in
point the leader of that group is
originally called Jim Crow in the script
however someone pointed out the crows
are actually positive since they're some
of the only characters who help Dumbo
and identify with this outsider status
we've add the rest of these examples
aren't quite so easy to justify moving
on the original cut of Fantasia from
1940 features a sequence based on
Beethoven's Pastoral Symphony which
features centaurs and other Greek
mythical creatures getting ready for a
feast included in that sequence are two
servants centaurs named sunflower and O
tika who are clearly modeled after
african-american stereotypes they've
been cut from subsequent releases of the
movie or well not so much cut but more
so disguised by zooming in footage so
that you never see them on frame at any
point then there's the highly
inappropriate depiction of Native
Americans in 1953 as Peter Pan in Wich
tiger lily and her people acting
ridiculously wild ways and speaking
broken English and are repeatedly
referred to as savages and lady in the
[ __ ] from 1955 featured an extended
sequence depicting evil Siamese cats
with thick accent and plenty of other
offensive Asian stereotypes the worst
offender though is 1946 Song of the
South a movie you may not even know
about since it's never been released on
video in the United States you've
definitely heard one of its Tunes
zippity-doo-dah
which won the Academy Award for Best
Song in 1947 it's also appeared on some
Disney sing-along videos as well as
being heard on the Splash Mountain ride
at Disneyland but the movie's general
reliance on black stereotypes and racial
caricatures have made it what critics
call one of Hollywood's most resilient
lis offense
of racist texts Thanks and it makes all
those wieners and ding-dongs all over
the Little Mermaid sound almost cute now
huh
thanks for watching and don't forget to
Like and subscribe if you want more